[Music]
elizabeth is with us in uh charlotte
north carolina hi elizabeth how are you
hi dave hi ken i'm great how are y'all
better than i deserve i was in your fair
city yesterday speaking at elevation
church for my friend pastor steven
furtick it was a blast how are you how
can i help
wonderful
um yeah so i'm i'm doing great better
than i deserved as well
and i've got a problem my husband and i
we bought a truck
and we paid cash for it
but the dealership listed our bank as a
lien holder
so the dmv issued the title and sent it
to the bank
so now
uh the dmv says they can't reissue the
title without helene release from the
bank and the bank is saying well we
don't have a lien to release
and we're kind of going in circles here
how do i get my title back
well
this is this is that's ridiculous
okay yeah
the dealership can solve this they can
reissue the title
or your bank can quit being stupid and
release a lien that they don't have all
you gotta do is sign the back of the
title and say the lien is released
there's no it doesn't have to be an
accounting transaction for your bank
your bank's being an idiot
how do we get the title for the bank to
sign the back of it though where is the
title the title was met
it was never issued a good question well
if it was issued with a lien holder it
went to the lien holder it went to the
bank
that's that's what the dmv told us and
the is fans they don't have it oh they
do your bank is incompetent
yeah
who are you bank with bank of america or
something
a fifth third oh god
they're awful here we go
well yeah they're they're incompetent
for sure
and uh
sorry go ahead no that's okay
yeah so here's the thing
climb all up in your banker's face and
climb all up in this dealership's face
the dealership can reissue the title
okay
i mean and and for that matter you can
call the state
what was the state telling you
the state's saying we issued a title we
don't we issued a title we've done our
job and it had a lien on it
right yeah they're saying well the
dealership told us there was a lien
which i'm going that there wasn't and
the fine purchase paperwork i have does
say in all caps
under the lien holder box none
yeah well there's [ __ ] there's unbailing
you pay cash for pretty clear yeah how
much was the truck
it was 23 000 and changed
okay well what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
dance on the face of your banker
and get their attention and then i'm
going to change banks when this is over
because you have a horrible bank
and the other thing is i'm going to go
over the dealer and go guys look i
didn't do this you've got my money yeah
i don't have a title are you going to
solve this or am i going to have to have
an attorney contact you to solve this i
didn't create this problem it's not on
me to fix it you created this problem
it's on you to fix it yeah
i i i just don't know if the problem's
not at the dmv to be honest with you if
they're saying there's no the bank or
the the dmv is saying that the dealer
told them there was a lien yeah but the
but that's not adding up
i got to tell you that the dealer's
incompetent the dealer the finance
office at the dealership got sloppy
that's right they made a mistake instead
of going and fixing their mistake
they're running around acting like this
is elizabeth's problem
so i'm gonna make it some other people's
problems and you're gonna have to keep
you got 26 000 bucks on the line you got
to get a title
the dealer i mean this is like losing 26
dollars
like you lost twenty six thousand
dollars of my money you probably need to
find it
yeah so it sounds like the dealership
could fix it which may be a better route
than the bank just because the bank is
such a big bank maybe the dealership i i
agree with i think it's the dealer dave
that needs to fix it because this is
what they do that's the whole part this
is the problem with dealing with someone
like fifth third or bank of america
they're so big and they're so stupid and
they don't care yeah
a normal bank that cared could fix this
all that because there's no harm to the
bank whatsoever on releasing the lien on
the back of the title and releasing it
back to you even though there was never
any lane they don't have to do an
accounting entry some duper called a
banker needs to get the title out of the
box sign the back of it and send it to
you it's that simple
and the whole thing's over
but you got to find somebody with a
brain at fifth third bank good luck with
that
i mean that's a problem that's why i
tell people not to bank with these banks
like this we bank with smaller community
banks regional banks and credit unions
the only tell the time i tell people to
bank with people because you can
actually find a human being that a cares
and b has two brain cells
because if you had to if you had three
brain cells you would have quit your job
if you were at fifth third and gone and
gotten a good job
you know but no you're staying there
it means you hadn't listened to the king
coleman show and gone and gotten a good
job you know this is like the start of a
bad joke a car dealer a banker and a dmv
staffer walk into a bar into a car
and and between the three of them can't
find a brain cell this is the
triangulation of incompetence
it's like
[Laughter]
that's what she's stuck in the
triangulation of incompetence you are in
the
bermuda triangle of incompetence the dmv
a banker and a car dealer
this is the ramsey shot